quando falamos falando de um lugar de um
lugar de nunciação de um contexto pois
banho meu nome é carlos fernandes e eu
sou uma mulher negra e o que quer dizer
eu sou mulher que foi violada em frente
ao seu marido e que foi obrigado a
amamentar o filho do seu agressor porque
sua mulher não tinha leito qualidade
eu sou mulher foi forçada entregar o seu
trabalho seu filho para trabalhar em
casa desse mesmo agressor
eu sou uma mulher negra muitos de vocês
podem dizer sim mas essa história vem lá
atrás é dada altura da escravatura o que
eu digo é que os ativos e inativos
alimentos dessas narrativas antigas de
nós dizemos que estamos cristalizadas lá
no passado mas que vão tendo novos
aumentos vão se atualizando e vão
resultar em estereótipos que fazem cocô
nós prevemos as outras pessoas da sua
humanidade e eu disputei para estas
questões do racismo muito cedo na
infância na realidade da escola primária
na escola primária nós tínhamos um
hábito fantástico que era no final de
cada período e nós tínhamos uma festinha
dessas festinhas dos rapazes que estavam
com a sempre uma música dos xutos e
pontapés que era aquela saudade que já
tinha na minha casinha lá a e cantava
essa música e ir essa música eu tinha um
hábito que alimenta o debate
eu elogio a briga mais feia da turma
todos os anos é a mesma que abriga mais
feio da turma e hoje em couro é natureza
robusta e correr atrás dele e fugiu com
ela é super engraçado para tudo menos
para a natureza óbvio e então houve uma
única no treze não foi à aula não foi à
aula e outros cantaram novamente a
música dos xutos e pontapés e e ouviram
igual
a briga mais foi a da turma quem abriga
mais cheia de tula e tahar lula eu
congelei fiquei presa dentro dos meus
pensamentos e como se olhar ao lado de
clark foi tudo muito rápido como se
olhar para os lados e de isabella é mais
feio do que eu
sofia o que a filha é mais feio do que
eu mas também é mais bonito do que eu
saiba o que é a história mais bonita do
que eu eu fiquei pensamos por que o
senhor briga mais feio da turma e um dos
rapazes disse é caro porque ela é preta
e um cêntimo desaparecer a carla que eu
conhecia dizer por seu e a feia
substituiu a partir do momento em que o
meu corpo diz
é caro ainda no universo que é a
infância mas nessa altura já era
professora eu dava aulas de inglês numa
escola primária ano na margem sul a 20
alunos entre os chefes e os oito anos eu
tenho que dar aulas eu adoro crianças e
achava que ser o máximo mas eu sei das
aulas em contendo esses suicídios porque
e 20 crianças dos 6 aos 8 não é
engraçado e meia faz hoje é a vez do
final das aulas vinha sempre uma outra
criança com um design com carinho e eu
ficava toda vestida a mulher deixar a
casa da mãe dela mas nem sempre vinham
com desenhos e carinhos em um dia em que
um dos meus alunos vêm ter comigo e vias
pitcher um chamava minha mãe disso que
os pretos são ladrões e são bandidos
ok eu sei que estão a fazer estas esta
criança é assim eu sou preta e utilizou
o termo preta o termo dele acho que eu
já estava suficientemente aparelhado
para fechar as contas ainda negro
deveria utilizar empresa que utiliza
para ofender mas o juiz entendeu eu
disse eu sou preta e no roubo e também
não sou bandida e o menino viesse mas a
minha mãe disse
e que está a questão do dizer novamente
quando era menina não é na escola ou na
escola disseram é carla briga mais feia
do turma disseram eu passei a ser
observado antes não configurado aí que
novamente essa criança e diz que os
negros costumo dizer que os negros são
ladrões e bandidos
a empresa era uma verdade o que foi dito
ainda mais por uma autoridade que se a
mãe deu
eu quero que nós ficamos com esta
questão de dizer que eu vou tomar é mais
tarde
então este episódio foram fazendo com
que o afastasse da realidade que seria
portugal quer uma realidade que não
abraçava quer uma realidade que eu não
vi porque eu realmente achava que ela
não é
então fui me afastando e fui tentando
procurar um lugar em outros espaços
perguntar elenco com a áfrica por
exemplo é que o aproximar da época que
era a escolha mais lógica aproxima da
áfrica através do livro através da
música amigos no carro que eu queria
freqüentar também é não funcionou muito
bem e procurei minha mãe enquanto então
como é que nós devíamos de angola
aconteceu como é que é
e minha mãe contou com sua conta
histórias do como nós atravessamos rios
em canoas como sua falar com meu pai
negociou em estradas bloqueadas com
militares era a minha história só também
parece uma história de indiana jones
perfil muito ficcional saúde tanto então
também não conseguia próxima dessa
história venda da minha mãe
já a idade adulta também eu consegui fui
trabalhar e viver em angola os angolana
teve angola e chega ao perceber e vamos
pra angola eu fui para meu país vou
apressar o país depois a apressarem vai
ser um grande reencontro não aconteceu
não aconteceu mais uma vez fui lançado
por uma realidade que não era a minha na
realidade a eu pensei eu tenho que
procurar meu espaço
eu vou procurar meu espaço no local onde
eu fiz a minha socialização eu curti
portugal barra europa
em 2014 eu criei um um projeto que o
áudio blog a rádio afro lixa é o blog
reúne 81
ligação com pessoas como eu
afro descendentes que vivem é que eles
boa daí o nome aafron lixo é uma junção
e que nós fazemos aqui nós conversamos
com outras pessoas que vivem aqui claro
a gente viver em lisboa
temos conversas e do parte para paris
para criar hábitos do pronunciação por
isso eu falei da questão de nós
tentarmos é reter o dizer é que neste
espaço da feliz nós dizemos nós falamos
sobre a nossa realidade
então quando fala sobre a realidade da
partida do já está a agir sobre a mesma
já estava fazendo com que ela muda com
aquelas ao tetra
é óbvio que nós como afrodescendentes
viver em lisboa nós não nos vamos
associar ao frio
nós não nos vamos associar ao bandido e
nós não devemos associar ao ladrão
nós estamos a tentar criar uma
identidade própria
a flor lisboeta da será um momento já
que habitam lisboa como se ela fosse a
sua terra sua terra mãe
alguém que tenha freqüência e e vive
nesse espaço
é uma pessoa que vai da áfrica áfrica de
língua portuguesa ou não mas que vai da
áfrica e que passou a gostar tanto disto
que deixou se ficar vai de férias quando
pode quando consegue mas é aqui que
passa é viver que é o meu caso
no afã de poeta eu acho que aquilo que
tem um suingue no pé porque gosta de
dançar porque a flor mas também é um
esgoto por ter uma mãe europeu e tem tem
manias do europeu tem luxos europeu né
a flor lisboeta galeria especial e em
especial à família do atleta é um
conjunto coisas das riquezas
às vezes fico triste por um
aproveitamento não há um aproveitamento
propriamente dito né
mas penso que se não vai dar que fazer é
dar que falar
e é a partir deste lugar denúncia são
que nós tentamos tratar a nossa
realidade aqui em lisboa através do
estádio blog e que acontece nós queremos
mudar o que está a acontecer queremos
mudar a narrativa porque é uma forma
também que eu acredito que podemos
combater o racismo o racismo que existe
uma de opção
nós temos que ter oportunidades para nos
pronunciar para dizer mas para nós
dizemos também temos que criar condições
para sermos ouvidos
temos que ser ouvidos também e quando
nós dizemos e ouvimos nós estamos a
assumir uma posição
e porquê dessa posição nós podemos agir
no contexto do que é o combate ao
racismo neste caso é uma coisa que não é
assim tão fácil de contornar uma vez fui
ao hospital com a cabeça aberta
escovar certo ponto de um lado e quatro
pontos do outro américa serviço vai ter
comigo como se eu acusei elvira assim
ele está doente e ela estado está
fazendo a opção e ele está mesmo do
verde e assim não pode estar doente
porque eu já dei uma polêmica durante o
dia e está doente
ela continua a fazer do penta
ela vira as famílias assim entanto já
não dói demais anos dizia ela decidiu
vai voltando aos quatro espaços que nós
temos que ouvir quer dizer ouvir-se
posicionamos e também agir américa
realmente gil mas ela não se posicionou
eu acho que é uma coisa que acontece
muitas vezes com vaz e silva muitas
pessoas querem combater o racismo mas
não falam sobre o racismo é uma ação
muitas vezes mas não falam sobre o
racismo a muitas etapas que nós
provavelmente saltamos e achamos que
estamos a contribuir para isso parece
com button mas temos que tentar
coordenar é esses três passos
não é fácil mas eu acho que vale a pena
tentar
e eu queria agora terminar a minha toca
convosco porque eu sei que não é difícil
não é fácil é tentarmos agir não é fácil
visualizar o que é o problema eu comecei
esta minha troca dizendo eu sou
uma mulher negra eu sou mulher que foi
violada em frente ao seu marido e que
amamentou o filho do seu agressor ainda
deu seu próprio filho para o trabalho
forçado em casa desse mesmo agressor
eu não quero continuar a repetir essa
história eu não quero continuar a falar
deste lugar denunciação eu quero mudar
essa história não quero continuar a ser
a vítima
eu não quero que o meu marido continua a
ser o a
como é que chama pessoa que não faz nada
que não consegue fazer nada
o impotente não quero que outra mulher
sair já que a mulher branca neste caso
seja a pessoa que está passiva eu não
quero que o homem branco continua a ser
o meu agressor
eu quero mudar essa história mas não vou
conseguir mudar sozinha eu vou precisar
da vossa ajuda e então eu vou pedir
todos almejam brancos com sua vantagem
por favor
e digo a frase eu vou dizer esse crime
está bom eu sou um homem branco
obrigada nesta tarde o pai vou pedir
também a todas as mulheres brancas que
se levantem por favor
e que digam a frase foi de mim eu sou
uma mulher branca
obrigada
peço tudo os homens negros que se
levantem e que digam depois de mim eu
sou um homem negro
obrigada
peço a todas as mulheres negras que se
levantem e digam depois de mim eu sou
uma mulher negra
obrigado
como vocês viram nós viram e ouviram nós
já nos posicionamos a partir desta
posição que nós acabamos de assumir quem
é que nós queremos ouvir histórias é que
nós queremos ouvir e como é que nós
queremos agir
o item
o tempo
né